welcome back to be continued discussion
on nokia tk
[music]
if we know the nokia stability
horn stability like the discussed alpha
die case and battery case no 8
discussion of scale model band the
transition from various nokia states
champion complete mission but photo
hamatech ape  the tipi important
indications follow alpha tk provider tk
who you stranger the daughter nuclear
left over the next stage and if the
management followers to the mission
overwhelm
practitioners consequence of the success traffic light
in fish process risks sound of
energy company reads photo news of the
mission is on the photo  ssp experiment as much
as nokia spectroscopy advertise the
chancellor detector now we wanted to get
into the picture to hear the
spade it is costanzos energy transition
with the photos of the center
this stay here and then in the tail
you disney pixar disney war no
attack dog  effect all photos videos and
electron positron ps one or two of space
in cases  who when electron opposition
and botox mfz action cinema whenever i
look to you find spectrum so song the
weary she comes us come
catering the pens office until round
in the compositions so until single a
double skate canada tourism provide
materials looking at is the nokia
spectroscopy can learn about is traffic light
composition element composition
interesting effect it is perfect
apply here remind you of the discussion
of the city look the energy on mid
season photo np cosmic process
like left over lux which you gave me at the
moment to balance oracle and  sap with
stars moving and because it's moving
half of the middle photo lg innotek wanted
energy needed in the offside
if you were license energy spectrum
here the natural joke antonius
overlapping slides here weekend saw v
effect the head of the district of viersen ots range
scanner professor recording
academy to  situation on the b b happy
objects
the mission 1